we had two patients died during the day
today and four more almost died I don't
know how people have been working like
this I just too much for me
[Music]
today is April 14th I am headed to New
York I really have never seen the same
resistible Airport this empty I mean
there's just nobody here so I got a long
flight ahead of me but be there soon and
get settled in when the covin pandemic
hit i really had a strong sense of guilt
about not being on the frontlines not
taking care of patients and not feeling
like i was doing all that I could was
everybody is on oxygen and almost
everybody is a Cove occasionally about
8:40 in the morning I'm heading in to
the hospital like I'm guessing this is a
later start than most of my days will be
but I'm just gonna get orientation and
get tested for my mask and so on Here I
am so home hi PPE on my head I just came
out of the unit so I took off my gown
and gloves but you see its head these
goggles are a little big on my face I've
got my n95 under here my head is small
this is a lot of equipment with my face
anyway I'll check back more later so I
just got back to my hotel
I just wanted to capture what my face
looks like after not even that many
hours so I'm probably gonna start using
band-aids like pre-emptive band-aids I
was told that the hospital typically has
50 ICU beds and they've now got 200
because of all the conversions they've
done to help take care of patients in
the current pandemic
[Music]
it's about 10:00 p.m. on April 17th
pretty early in my shift I had a patient
who got a lot worse very quickly and he
was actually of the five pages I was
taking care of he was the healthiest one
so I really hadn't mentally prepared for
that we were able to give him the
treatment that he needed and he's doing
much better now
but I think that was a very quick
introduction to how patients do when
they've got this disease that they can
be fine one minute and then just really
not the next they're very very dependent
on the oxygen support that they're
receiving is April 18th pretty early in
the morning so here we are it's my
second night here in the ICU so far I
had one patient who coded meaning nearly
died last night and I had another
patient who coded tonight and
unfortunately he didn't make it and I
just got off the phone with the
patient's family and I can definitely
see how doing this day in and day out
would get very very hard it is almost 2
a.m. on April 20th I really feel like
I'm on a roller coaster right the first
couple of nights I was here were worse
than I thought they would be in terms of
how the patients were doing tonight from
the time I walked in
there were a number of patients who
really needed kind of emergency care I'm
not sure what's gonna happen with those
patients it's too soon to tell but we've
had to be pretty aggressive in our
interventions but you know the patient
who almost died last night is still here
so that's some cause for hope a lot of
these patients even if they had normal
kidneys before have had injuries to
their kidneys from the disease and from
their blood pressure being low and
having trouble with oxygen and so now
they need to dialysis there's only so
many machines there's only so many
nurses there's only so many hours in a
day so who gets it who is deciding who
gets it hmm I'm signed up to be
rationing care I don't think any of us
did so that's kind of the latest
struggle noticing a lot of things that
are different from you know normal times
for example in the ICU typically if we
need changes made to a ventilator if we
have patients who need suctioning or
anything like that there would be a
respiratory therapist who provide that
care I think that there aren't quite
enough of them to go around so I've
learned how to manipulate all sorts of
ventilators we also have many different
kinds of ventilators usually an
intensive care unit you have the same
model throughout the unit but we have at
least 3 or 4 different kinds here many
of which are not intended to be used in
a continuous basis they're made for
transportation so temporary use from to
get a patient from one place to another
there are challenges in getting x-rays
challenges
and getting certain types of medications
these are all things that are different
from what would normally be happening I
mean if we had all the resources it is
the morning of April 20th around 9:00
a.m. I gotten home from my shift and
showered and I'm getting ready to go to
sleep last night we had a couple of
patients who were close to dying but
neither of them did one of them had
gotten quite sick overnight and we
wanted to call the family so that they
could have a chance to communicate with
her an anticipation that this might be
the last opportunity that they would
have and this was the first time that I
actually watched it happen so one of my
colleagues called the patient's family
and then stood over the patient's bed
holding her her phone up so that they
could see her and I listened to them try
to say goodbye
over the phone they couldn't help but
think about you know that were my mother
how awful that would be to not be able
to hold her hand don't you know that she
was alone anyway I just wish it didn't
have to be like this and I'm glad I
haven't had to watch that 20 times or 40
times or however many times in the last
few weeks because I don't I'm not I'm
not cut out for that but I'm gonna try
to watch something like hard-headed
didn't go to sleep it's position for
used to fixing problems and helping
people that's why we do what we do but
when we don't have medications at work
when there aren't ventilator settings
that can help people get enough oxygen
and get rid of their carbon dioxide it
feels very frustrating on top of that a
lot of the doctors here have friends or
colleagues who are critically ill in
other hospitals in New York and so
they're constantly thinking about and
worried about those people in addition
to being worried about their patients
and many of them are living apart from
their families in order to prevent
infecting their family members so
they're going through this very
stressful challenging time basically on
their own so far it seems to me that
most of the people are coping by really
not thinking about it and not processing
it I'm just showing up and doing the
work as best they can and hoping things
get better now I'm working days feeling
less like the vampire and today somewhat
miraculously was actually kind of a good
day we had a patient who was able to
come off the ventilator which is pretty
incredible because I think that hasn't
happened actually in this unit since the
unit opened we're at the point now where
we're starting to see fewer people get
admitted every day
so things are I think starting to slow
down a little bit which is great
the patience we have now though are all
really really sick and probably will be
here for quite a while so it's not like
it's totally over it is April 24th
I had a patient today who was writing
notes so he's on the ventilator with the
breathing tube but he was hand writing
notes to people and we FaceTime with his
family and you know he's mentally very
with it and knows what's happening
but he's requiring a lot of oxygen from
the ventilator to get oxygen into his
tissues and he's also on the younger
side so it's very hard to watch because
I just don't know whether he's going to
get out of this so far of all the people
I've seen on the ventilator who have
been really sick the way he is only one
person in the last 10 days has been able
to get off the ventilator but he wrote
today I'm not giving up so even with a
breathing tube and all sorts of IVs and
tubes coming out of everything and being
on all the medication that he's on he's
not giving up it is April 25th at least
today when I came in no one had died
overnight and hopefully no one will die
today if that happens I'll be the first
24-hour period since I've been here that
we would have had no deaths in our
little unit I'm supposed to be leaving
the hospital a few hours ago but one of
my patients I almost died just as I was
about to leave so I stayed to try to
take care of him and to talk to his
family here
anyway so it's 11:30 now we had two
patients died during the day today and
four more almost died it's just just in
the last couple of hours you have one
good day and then have a really really
awful day right after what I miss my
staircase I don't know how people have
been working like this I just too much
for me I know I'm gonna sleep even
tonight because I'm gonna be worried
about this guy and whether he's gonna
make it I can't stay here all night I
gotta be here so I'm gonna go see if I
can get some rest
that is April 26 yesterday was it was a
rough day and it was long and we lost
two patients during the day neither one
was totally unexpected but it's still
hard to see as I was about to leave
we actually had four patients who got
really really sick at the same time and
came close to dying one of them was a
patient I was falling closely and I felt
I guess sort of attached to I just
didn't feel like I could leave when he
was that sick so I ended up staying
until we got him
sort of stabilized um I mean he was
still quite ill but it seemed like we
had helped him a little bit so I had to
call his family and help them to
FaceTime with him because I wasn't sure
if he was gonna make it through the
night and I always feel like I'm
intruding when I'm when I'm there and
I'm hope I have to be there except hold
the camera we don't have a holder the
patient obviously can't hold it
themselves so it's it's very hard to
hear people tell their family member to
fight and that their they can get
through this especially when as a
physician I I'm not really sure in that
moment that they are gonna get through
it
but we all need a little hope I also
think I'm just very sleep-deprived I I
don't think I've slept more than five
hours at a time since I've been here and
I haven't had any days off which is my
choosing I think I think he would have
been happy for me to have a day off but
I just felt like I'm here for a limited
time and I wanted to do the most that I
could do it is April 28th and I'm about
to head out to the airport just been
reflecting back a little bit on my
experience here in New York you know I
don't really know exactly what I
expected
I hadn't really thought about the
emotional toll I had thought about you
know the medical care and how
challenging that could be since we don't
know much about this disease of the
people I took care of with Kovan ammonia
they all either have died or remain
critically ill in the hospital at this
point just in two weeks here seeing this
much death has been really really hard
for me so they're already 5 or 6 weeks
into this now and even as things slow
down and get a little bit better they
really need time to recuperate and we
don't know when things will get worse
again which i think is really
psychologically challenging I'm thinking
about if there's a second wave you know
I would like to come back and what are
the skills I should try to gain between
now and then to be the most helpful to
people here so I'll be thinking about
all of them and hoping for the best
I am back home now in California I just
had a nasal swab done yesterday to see
if I was Co fit positive which was not a
pleasant experience they take a swab and
put it basically straight back going
back towards your brain and then they do
that on both sides just you know in case
and I got my result tonight and I am
magically somehow negative I really am
perplexed as to how that's possible
given that I was really exposed to a lot
of kovat for a couple of weeks for many
hours a day but I'll take it as a win I
mean it could be a false negative I
suppose but I'm just gonna I'm gonna
roll with that